the jurogan experience i'm very excited
to talk to you because i had a guy on
jamie metzel yesterday a scientist who
scared the [ __ ] out of me
talking about china he's talking about
china we were talking about china
amassing naval power china's
taking over tech companies and how
how huge they're getting and how much
influence they have over their people as
opposed to the way
we do it well it's not wrong yeah i
can't spot the lion in what what you
just said but
uh i mean look i mean there's so much we
can we can talk about but
if you think about it just in the past
handful of months
there was this solar winds hack right by
the russians
so the russians go in they hack into a
company called solarwinds that
is an i.t management software company
that happens to be
um fairly deep into government
organizations agencies
treasury and a variety of others
throughout the us government
and they're also into parts of the intel
community defense department
uh in a lot of commercial sectors so
anyway the russians figure this out
now around about december or january
um microsoft you know identified this as
a problem and
and i think it was the head of microsoft
said this looks like the most
sophisticated attack
we've ever seen so this is december
january time frame
and they're still trying to figure out
the depth of this hack by russians
at the same time and going back months
and months and months and months before
the chinese had been engaged in
a more sophisticated attack that
while everyone is focused on what's
going on and so fully aware that we got
problems right from
from nation states out there who don't
like us
everybody's talking about solo wins and
now it's you know they've just now
released information about the chinese
attack against uh microsoft exchange
servers uh running the exchange email
systems
and this thing is uh
enormous and so the chinese yeah i mean
we've been so focused for four years on
the russians you know and they're you
know
they they're out there to cause us all
sorts of problems so we should be
focused on them
but it's china that's the biggest
problem and so this guy is absolutely
right jamie's right it was terrifying
yeah listen to what he was talking about
the way he was
explaining how they you know they have
this
plan i think he said 2049 to be the the
global superpower of the world and
essentially be take the place of what
america used to be
yeah they do it their way and do it
their way which means
we're going to bypass all the costs and
the heavy lift of research and
development over the years
and which can steal everything and
they've been doing it for decades so
people think oh china it's a problem
it's a pr
we've talked about this before you know
this idea that perhaps this is just
something relatively new or it's popped
up during the previous administration of
trump
and honest guys truth is it's been going
on for decades
and they decided that that's how they're
going to get to the top of the food
chain
is by stealing [ __ ] because it's a lot
easier to hoover up
everything and then reverse engineer it
and the technology has made it even
easier right it used to be old school
they'd go out and recruit somebody
they'd find some chinese-american
working for a company
here in the states they'd appeal to sort
of you know you got to help the
motherland
and and they would and that was the
old-school way of doing it but
you know cyber theft is it's incredible
what they're able to do and this latest
attack while they they're still trying
to sort out the mess
right so when they do this so if they
get into this email
server are they targeting
anything specific is there specific
companies are they just like
throwing a net out there and seeing what
they catch yes is the answer to
uh both of those it's
it looks like what happened here was
that
um their their initial
point of attack or the initial focus was
uh intelligence
right so then it branched out and it
branched out very very quickly right
to hit everything small companies
medium-sized companies
and that's kind of the mo for the the
chinese the chinese
regime right the uh and their intel
operations
uh they've got this long vision and
they've also got the resources and
they've got the desire to hoover up
everything and then sort it out later we
take
as as a country we take a very sort of
targeted approach
right we say okay this is a piece of
information that's a priority tasking
for the u.s for our national security
we're going to go out we're going to
figure out who has access to it we're
going to
develop a very sort of surgical strike
to figure out how do we get to somebody
who's got this piece of information
that's
typically how we or some of our allies
would operate
the russians the chinese have always had
a different approach i mean the russians
is less elegant the russians
just throw [ __ ] at the wall and see what
sticks right but the chinese
they've got this long view and they've
also got this ability and they'll so in
this particular attack that they're
still trying to assess
that was perpetrated by you know
um chinese state-sponsored hackers
based in china uh they uh
they're just gonna take everything and
then they'll sift through it they'll
figure out what they got
a lot of it's going to be just you know
chafe not not of interest
but they're going to find a lot of gold
in there too and they're willing to do
that because they've got the patience to
do it
they'll they'll develop a target they'll
develop a potential recruit
for years and years and years or they'll
they'll infiltrate
um a society or an organization right
they'll put a student out here who's
actually working for the pla for their
intel operations
and they'll put them out as an undergrad
and then they'll go to school
and they'll get good grades and they'll
go to a grad school and they'll get a
job and they'll get another job and then
30 years down the line it may pay off
but they're willing to make that
investment
so all right so we should be scared
well we shouldn't be scared but we said
yeah
uh we i don't think we should be scared
but i think what we should be is
is pragmatic and understand why uh
for instance i mean there was a lot of
you know human cry over the past four
years
i can't believe i just said he wouldn't
cry i don't even know what that means i
don't
know
it's old-timey is it yeah oh my golly
look at me it's like the cat's pajamas
um
it's uh so you know four years of trump
and sort of his antagonistic
relationship with china and people were
all ringing their hands in washington dc
you know
sort of the the think tankers and the
traditional pundits and the diplomats
of of of of the us you know the
long-term people
oh my god we've got this adversarial
relationship with china well you know
what we better
right so that's not a bad thing so i'm
hoping the current administration
maintains to some degree
and we'll see what happens they still
haven't responded to the solar winds to
the russian attack
right they're talking about it now
they're saying they're gonna they're
gonna engage in several clandestine
uh retaliatory acts well
it's not that clandestine because
they've announced that they're gonna do
it
um and so you know but but i'm hoping
that
they will take serious action uh uh
against the the solarwinds russian act
but
they've got to with china they've got to
maintain
this uh posture we've got to uh
make it clear and understood to the
chinese regime
that we're not going to put up with this
[ __ ] they're going to keep doing it but
we've got to make it painful for them so
how do you make it painful
well you know it's the old word
sanctions you got to go with the
sanctions because there's not much else
trade wars you know i know everybody
hates the trade war
not everybody but um you've you you've
got to find a way because the problem
with with cyber
uh shenanigans is that there's no real
clear definition right we know if we if
if a country fires a ballistic missile
off uh
you know we know what the retortality or
retaliatory act is we know what an
appropriate response is
in cyberspace when you're talking about
warfare
coming up with a definition is very
difficult and hasn't been done yet we've
got cyber command right and we're still
trying to sort out
what are appropriate responses because
it can escalate quickly right
next thing you know they could shut down
our infrastructure right well that's
what i wanted to talk to you about
supposedly what they did in india
so if you could explain that to people
they shut down the power grid in india
allegedly they said they didn't do it
but apparently there was some sort of a
warning about the power going out
right yeah um they've done it um i mean
the russians did
it famously in ukraine right i mean not
that long ago and
um china's ability to
interfere uh in uh infrastructure here
in the u.s or in india or
with our allies it's because for years
now they've been probing there's been
testing going on you know they're we
you know we talk about um it's a good
example
we talk about how um in the u.s we have
three grids and i think people
were stunned to find out that texas has
its own power grid well
yeah uh but it's not so much people were
like oh my god look at texas they're
terrible because you know they wanted to
make it a political thing right they
wanted to make it sound like
the reason why it's so terrible is
because it's
republicans and they've got they want
their own independence well
no all three grids are [ __ ] right the
east and the west and
and the texas grids are all cobbled
together over the years
so it's a very sort of it's like a
patchwork quilt
and they were never built to withstand
uh physical attacks i mean you could
drive by any substation right you could
get close enough to pee on it
and there's they they certainly were
never designed to to withstand a cyber
attack
so over the years
what goes on is essentially a mapping
exercise right
where whether it's the russians whether
it's the chinese whether it's the north
koreans using chinese capabilities
whether it's the iranians whomever
they're in there probing and trying to
understand the weaknesses and they're
drawing up a map now the reason why
they're doing that
is to have a game plan right and i
guarantee you
sitting on the desk somewhere not too
far from you know g's office
is a playbook that says if this thing
escalates
here's what we're going to do and if you
think like
it was bad in texas you know a couple
weeks ago when you know the power was
out
and it was bad but think about that
lasting for
eight 10 12 weeks around the country
right
power grid shut down what happens you
can't transport [ __ ] right you can't get
cash
fuel doesn't get to to the gas stations
food doesn't get to the stores
uh this you know depending on the time
of year heat issues obviously
water supplies uh and that's where the
next big battle is going to be fought
right they're going to bring it to the
homeland and we will do the same thing
right it's not like we're not doing it
because people always say when i say
something like that well the u.s does it
too
i think well [ __ ] yeah the u.s does it
we're better we better hope
we're we're prepared does that frost you
frustrate you when people say that
well the us does it too yeah it does in
a sense because and this is where i
think um
you know that now personal opinion comes
into it look i spent most of my
my adult life overseas and
i like to think that i've got a fairly
pragmatic view on things
i do admit that i you know obviously
look i look at the us
and i like to think and i have seen on
occasions we do a lot of things for for
the right reason sometimes we don't do
it
properly right we make mistakes of
course we make mistakes
uh but we try to self-correct i
guarantee you if we're talking about the
major powers out there if we're talking
about china and us we're talking the
chinese regime i'm talking about
obviously if we're talking about
the russians the iranians north koreans
we better hope that we stay up there
right and are able to uh exert influence
and leverage and control the top right
because
if it's if it's and again i maybe i'm
wrong here
but the chinese don't view anything in
an altruistic manner the chinese regime
right
it's all about self-interest and
sometimes i'll tell you what's
frustrating sometimes is we seem to be
the only country out there that
apologizes right for that sort of thing
and so when we act in our own best
interests and we go well we're really
sorry about that
you know we're kind of acting in our
best interests well every other nation
does it and they don't give a [ __ ] yeah
but shouldn't we be the moral high
ground for the world
i think we should i think it's nice if
we do all the same [ __ ] they do we say
sorry
yes as long as we do all this i guess it
doesn't cost anything to say sorry it's
not a bad thing it's not a bad thing
we're setting a tone yeah i guess that's
true as long as we're as long as we're
also then at the same time
acting at our own best yeah because we
have to be again we have to be pragmatic
if we think that somehow you know look
at climate change that's obviously it's
back on the table it's a big issue as a
major policy direction
hey fine great who doesn't want clean
energy but you know
to to to act as if china's not the
you know the number one polluter out
there is insane yeah that's that's where
it gets weird
yeah it does it gets a little weird
giant difference between the amount of
particulates the amount of pollution the
amount of co2
you know um i think they've they've
tried hard to mitigate that over the
last few years in particular but you
remember when they had the beijing
olympics
yes and they had to shut everything down
because the air quality was so
bad that the athletes you know would it
would actually be dangerous for the
athletes to
to perform and to compete catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience